lorsque le maire nous fait la visite de
tournus il ne manque pas de projets
alors le but ici ce serait de faire des
terrasses de café de revoir complètement
la disposition générale de revoir la
place de la voiture pour y faire
vraiment un lieu sympathique attractif
réaménagement de deux places d'un
quartier de logement ou encore
modernisation de la bibliothèque
les idées sont là et 2 millions d'euros
sont sur la table pour revitaliser le
bourg
pourtant il y en a encore deux ans ce
n'était pas gagné
un projet de centre commercial en
périphérie de la ville avait provoqué un
tollé
jusqu'au départ de l'ancien maire les
habitants s'étaient mobilisés pour
sauver le centre ville aujourd'hui pour
le nouveau maire c'est de l'histoire
ancienne
tiens un frémissement il ya eu cinq
demandes de permis de construire sa part
arrivé depuis des années quand on
regarde tournus depuis un an à peu près
on voit des grues partout on n'a jamais
eu autant de personnes privées qui ont
refait leur toiture qui sont en train de
refaire leur façade
donc on voit que la ville commence à se
transformer et ça c'est très
enthousiasmant
premier bénéficiaire de cet élan le
cinéma de la ville entièrement remise à
neuf pour la ville impensable de le
laisser tomber en désuétude il ya qu un
cinéma à 30 kilomètres à la ronde et
6000 habitants à tournus mais on touche
la communauté de communes voire des
villages un peu plus loin pour ne pas
dire mais mâcon chalon sur notre
programmation plus pointue
du coup ça oblige les gens à venir en
voiture à venir à tournus fait revenir
faire revenir les gens à tournus un
objectif qui a de quoi séduire tout le
monde et c'est mathématique
ce commerçant y trouve son compte en
plus de gens qui viendront dans le
sortent donc potentiellement riche de
clients et aussi en termes
d'attractivité
touristique parce que si on réhabilite
des logements simon réhabilite les
ruelles
si on met en avant les avantages que
représente la saône les vieux quartiers
on aura plus de gens qui viendront
peut-être se promener peut-être faire
des achats
la ville attire de nouveaux
investisseurs cet entrepreneur s'est
lancé dans la construction d'un hôtel
grand luxe
pour lui il n'ya qu'un avenir possible à
tournus ce qui peut sauver tournus c'est
le tourisme
alors c'est bien par l'accueil de
l'hôtellerie par l'abbaye qui est
présente par les musées par
l'environnement qu'on peut créer autour
de tournus et l'année mais au quotidien
à l'heure où les centres villes sont
plutôt victimes de fermeture de
commerces
le plan de revitalisation du bourg signé
avec la région est une petite bouffée
d'oxygène